a new 200 million dollar tech school
opening next year in North Las Vegas
before it does Clark County Schools
looking to hire about 100 teachers
that's right well the Northeast Career
and Technical Academy will be located on
Deer Springs and North fifth not far
from the 215 Beltway and next to Legacy
High School eight news now reporter
Joshua peguero looks into how the school
is filling a need in the area by
offering students a magnet school
education
Sophia froggy dacus knew she wanted to
go to a Clark County magnet school when
she was in Middle School it's hard work
you have to really put in that hard work
I would say in middle school starts the
17 year old is a senior a veterans
should be Career and Technical Academy
studying to pursue a career in forensics
she is applying to colleges for the fall
I've enjoyed it I wouldn't change it for
anything else I've had a really good
time I've made a lot of good friends
that I have for the rest of my life
Clark County has 42 Magna schools that
specialize in the Arts stem and Industry
trades most are allowed to refer a
mission but students must apply first
and meet certain criterias Ryan Cordia
is the incoming principal for the
Northeast Career and Technical Academy
so if you want to learn how to be a
social worker if you want to learn about
clean energy or if you want to learn
about
logistics Northeast Career Tech's the
only spot to learn those there will be
about 500 to 600 freshmen inside this
building when it opens next August and
the district is currently in need of a
hundred teachers the tech school will
offer 10 programs that school leaders
work with several local Industries to
develop and so I want to make sure
everyone who signs up for our school has
access to whatever they want to be and
has the skills to do that the deadline
to apply for the Magna School Lottery is
January 10th the lottery takes place in
March Joshua progero 8 News Now